[Musique]
danseuse chanteuse actrice résistante
militants antiracistes joséphine baker
apporté bien des casquettes 46 ans après
sa disparition
cette grande dame fait son entrée dans
le temple des grands hommes un parcours
hors normes depuis son missouri natale
né en 1906 dans une famille très pauvre
d'artistes freda josephy mcdonald's doit
travailler dès son plus jeune âge à 13
ans elle se marie pour la première fois
mais les noces tournent court éprise de
liberté la jeune fille qui danse depuis
son plus jeune âge rejoint un trio
d'artistes de rue joséphine voit grand
et décide de tenter sa chance à new york
c'est là qu'elle est en fait remarquer
on lui propose un spectacle à paris en
1925 l'américaine débarque en france
elle triomphe au sein de la revue
au théâtre des champs-elysées en
quelques années elle devient l'égérie du
tout-paris la reine des années folles
elle s'essaye aussi à la chanson et au
cinéma lorsque la seconde guerre
mondiale éclate elle n'hésite pas elle
met son talent au service de son nouveau
pays elle devient agent du
contre-espionnage français elle fait
passer les informations sur ces
partitions de musique et soutient les
troupes alliées en donnant des concerts
nommé sous-lieutenant elle sera décoré
de la légion d'honneur de la croix de
guerre avec palmes et de la médaille de
la résistance avec rosette à la
libération elle s'engage dans le combat
pour les droits civiques aux états unis
elle participe notamment à la marche sur
washington en 1963 aux côtés de martin
luther king en france elle s'implique au
sein de la ligue internationale contre
le racisme
toute sa vie elle lutte contre les
inégalités elle décide d'adopter des
enfants de tous les continents une tribu
arc en ciel de 12 bambins qu'elles
élèvent au château des milandes en
dordogne criblé de dettes elle en est
finalement expulsé ruinée elle doit
continuer à chanter
[Musique]
en 1975 pour fêter ses 50 ans de
carrière elle monte sur la scène de
bobino mais elle décède des suites d'une
attaque cérébrale quelques jours après
la première
symbole d'émancipation celles qui
rêvaient d'une fraternité universelle a
gagné sa place au panthéon sa patrie
d'adoption lui est plus que
reconnaissante